c'est un très bon livre que la
biographie du leader cubain que publie
jean pierre clerc ou seuil sous le titre
les quatre saisons de fidel castro
journaliste au monde l'auteur connaît
remarquablement le contexte latino
américain et son style est ferme et
clair à peine regrettera ton qui ne
s'attardent pas davantage sur l'homme
castro que l'on ne saurait limiter à sa
seule action politique tout au départ de
l'aventuré castriste s'apparente à un
paradoxe
fidel est un fils d'espagnol riche et
catholiques élevé chez les frères
maristes et par les jésuites c'est dire
que l'armature intellectuelle de cet
orateur hors pair tôt révélé et des plus
solides
de surcroît castro comme beaucoup de ses
compatriotes est fasciné par les états
unis où il se rend en voyage de noces à
l'âge de 22 ans
quatre ans plus tard il prend les armes
ce sera le coup d'état manqué de la
moncada contre un batista qui s'est
autoproclamé et non sans quelques
raisons dictateur démocratique comme
lénine fidel castro réussira à sa
deuxième tentative
il y a de cela bientôt 40 ans la
révolution castriste trouvera en france
notamment des échos favorables est
incontestablement incarnera une forme
d'espoir elle démontrera aussi assez
vite ses limites
n'empêche qui aurait pu penser qu'un
fidel castro septuagénaire ferait un
jour figure de vétéran de la scène
politique mondiale